you're very good friends with one
celebrity Josh Groban a singer and I
sent it true that you guys are really
good friends yes we're good friends but
I'm gonna call him out Josh Groban a lot
of people don't know this he's a very
good singer he's what I call a man-whore
yeah you don't know this Josh he's been
getting the hottest in Hollywood as long
as I've known him that's right let's
clean this up a little all right enough
for your I don't want to shock the very
talkative you're talking like Trump yeah
all right so what if probes was one of
those prostitutes pissing on Trump okay
in nature wait a minute okay what you're
saying is that Josh Groban the famous
singer incredible range has a secret
life has a secret life where he enjoys
the company of many different women is
that what you're saying I'm saying that
he is the John Mayer of opera and I
lovingly confronted him one night
because he doesn't sing on tour he sings
a song called the prayer it's a
beautiful song he's done it with Celine
Dion and Charlotte Church and so he gets
someone from the audience to sing it
with him and of course they're never
that great and then he's fantastic and
so I was teasing him when I go for God's
sake robes it's so transparent you're
bringing like these 19 year old girls
onstage to sing with you I mean I see
you for who you are Groves and then
you're open goes look honey this isn't
itself
[Applause]
solutely stories
[Laughter]
you